[Music]
hey everyone its Alicia Malone is time
for more indie goodness on Fandango envy
movie guide and this week I have three
films which is each taken tried-and-true
genres the period piece the superhero
movie the monster film but given them a
real twist let's start with Lady Macbeth
but this is not your Shakespearean Lady
Macbeth although it is very dark and has
a lot of sin and some murder and a
little bit sex
you will remain indoors with your prayer
dog I like so sure I like being outside
of the nightdress
take it off that's the wall crystal wall
this film is directed by William Oldroyd
and it is an adaptation of an old
Russian novel it's set in rural England
in the 1860s where this young girl
played by Florence Pugh gets forced into
a marriage that is very very unhappy
when our husband goes away she manages
to escape from her compliance she falls
in love with a farmer and then all hell
breaks loose when her husband comes home
in fact it's all very shamelessly
it's all very stupidly you will never
see that man again
William Oldroyd is a stage director and
you can really tell with this movie it's
very theatrical in nature also very
carefully constructed and very confined
to just a few locations that really adds
to the claustrophobic quality of this
movie given mr. Lester's recent deny my
husband is not the CC as a funeral is
missing but presented
Florence Pugh is a star to watch she
holds the film with her magnetic appeal
it takes a lot of twists and turns and
it's very tense and Eric Kohn of
indieWIRE said it's as if Alfred
Hitchcock was directing weathering
Heights I love that idea in its very apt
description this is definitely a period
piece and it does recall watering
Heights with the misty moors beautiful
cinematography beautiful
costumes beautiful revenge you can see
Lady Macbeth in limited theaters from
this weekend my next film is one that
you can watch at home on Fandango now
from July 18 it's called slate and it's
a very different take on the superhero
genre as you can see there's no string
you know what she made a Holly you can
grab it out it should do that this does
Jacob Latimore who is a young guy who
has to play the very responsible role
when his mother passes away he is
looking after his sister and he's doing
what he can to make ends meet doing
magic on the street by day and selling
drugs by night meanwhile to help him
with his tricks he inserted a battery
into his arm and then it becomes like a
superhero arm there's a lot of things in
our lives like a traffic to these
various only exist a collision Erik
Davis from Fandango said that this was
like iron man meets Chronicle and once
again I agree with that comparison but
the thing that I love about flight is
that it does keep it very slight so it
keeps it very quiet very naturalistic he
doesn't want to be a superhero he just
wants to get out of his own situation I
gave you a job when you needed it most
I'm going to kill you and every person
you
me nothing we need to worry about just
heart being a grown up sometimes I think
it's really cool to make sure you check
it out at home it's light and it's
available on Sunday go now from July 18
now we can do whatever we want if we
just believe Able's and my last film is
also available on Fandango now from July
18 it is a very different take on a
monster movie called colossal starring
Anne Hathaway and Jason Sudeikis you
don't remember anything let's play huh
yeah really melodramatic didn't my told
me that you weren't really on a vacation
I loved this movie and I know that the
reviews were mixed but I want to tell
you why so Anne Hathaway stars as this
girl who needs to clean up her act she's
drinking too much she goes back home
she's trying to sort her life out she
becomes close to a character played by
Jason Sudeikis and then she discovers
that there's a monster in Seoul who is
causing havoc and she might be that
monster when she's drunk all right it's
just it's a nervous tic I have never did
you you can look at this idea of a
monster in various ways it could be the
monster that she's trying to tame within
herself this this demon that wants to
get really really drunk it could be the
monster that she becomes when she's
drunk or you could look at it as in she
is fighting the monster around her like
she is fighting Society and trying to
fight her way back
or that helicopter literally the pilot
and everything whatever way you look at
it you could just think it's just a
silly movie with Anne Hathaway being a
monster in Seoul but it is a good time
do I recommend you checking out colossal
if you haven't already it's available on
Fandango now from July 18 oh she's the
monster so three very different genre
movies for you this week in theaters the
period piece with a twist
Lady Macbeth at home the superhero movie
with a twist slide and also at home the
monster movie with a twist
colossal let me know in the comments
below if you've seen any of those movies
whether you enjoy them or not or if
you're looking forward to checking out
one that I've mentioned you can also
write to me on Twitter at Lisa Malone
and I'll see you next week right